so we all play video games yeah gamers
right so
i thought today that we could talk about
our tastes in gaming cause i think we we
spoke about what we like to play and all
that but we haven't actually sat down
and
reviewed each other's gaming properly or
at least tell each other our gaming
yeah so we've had like the anime episode
where we've probably
broken down our anime tastes even though
we've talked about anime before and
we're gonna be doing something similar
today so we have made
three three by threes for our games we
don't unfortunately we don't have a my
gaming list
which probably would have made it not a
thing i don't know that should be a
thing oh i'm sure there's like
i'm sure there's a thing of that but
it's just not i don't know it's just not
as prevalent in the gaming community i
feel
like i guess it's because it takes
longer to finish a game yeah
and it i'm gonna be honest it made this
a lot harder
because i couldn't remember like most of
the games i played
literally it's just proven
like i'm not looking forward to this
episode because i'm probably gonna have
the most boring gaming
godzilla's just going to be like the top
top selling games of all time
that's that's it we sports nine times
tetris we
sport like for me like the we were
making our three by threes at the same
time
these two finished within 10 minutes and
i after about half an hour i
made six and i'm just like are there
nine games i really care about i don't
know
i know i finished nine years nine games
i
care about what what are you had a
personal retirement home like
no it's more than nine games no i i have
games that i played
that i enjoyed but like games that like
really meant something to me or games
like i think back and have like a
positive
right just like you just think yeah i
hated it
every game
there were just so many games where i'm
just like yeah that was a game i played
you know like my father please stop
giving me shitty games
i don't want to play any shitty games i
enjoyed my time with it i don't know
i'm excited for this one because i feel
that you know with anime you guys are
like definitely the resident experts
right i feel like gaming this is like
this is
yeah like the reverse the the roles have
been reversed
i mean look if there's anything we know
about the gaming communities that they
love
to [ __ ] on other people's opinions all
right it's like i i feel like
regardless of what we put on here
there's going to be at least one person
being like
an amateur [ __ ] normies right here oh
definitely definitely i mean it depends
you know i mean i'm fully prepared for
i'm fully
i fully realize i'm a normie when it
comes to games so i'm okay with that to
be honest
you think you're a normie i think i am
the most normie gamer
the the list of games i've actually
completed is like i can probably count
on my hand
wait why why do you not complete games i
don't i find it
super super hard to complete games it
needs to be like
really good no that's the thing that's
the thing most of the like
because i tried to find the criteria of
like what i would put on my list right
and for anime it was
anime that i have at least re-watched
once for gaming i was just like
um if i complete that if i complete the
game then that's like a [ __ ]
s-tier game in my eyes because if it's
if if i get to the end of the game it
must be a truly special imagine if
people did this for like movies they're
like it's a good movie if i get to the
end yeah
like 10 out of 10. normally i log on
it's like reading an ign review being
like
i finished it nine out of 10. no no
because like because like for me
for me like the most most of most games
i get to that 70 percent
mark of completion right and at the 70
mark
it's like you've you've discovered most
of the things the game can do for you
right and like you've unlocked most of
the abilities like they literally don't
end until they end
like like which games know any on your
list or just anything
like games uh yeah talking about like
like online games well if you're doing
story games you know obviously you can't
just quit 70 of the way and be like i've
seen the story i mean like
you'd be surprised i mean a story that's
that's a [ __ ] dictionary you know
unusual knowledge
yeah and that's why i think for me um
story is a massive thing
because if it doesn't have a good story
i ain't finishing the game no
i agree with that if you don't have good
gameplay
if there is just one aspect of a game
that just doesn't mesh with me
immediately
then i just end up not playing it is
anything that annoys me more than a
picky eater it's a picky gamer
like finish your game i don't know
especially especially now when i just
don't have time to play games if i'm
playing a game i play like
i think i play one or two games a year
right new games like it's hard not to
just go back to my comfort food and play
games i've
played before i have such a bad habit on
that where if there's
ever like a new game that just comes out
i don't it doesn't matter if i
just started a new game three days prior
yeah let's be like
i don't want to play with you anymore
and then i just play that new like
so just three days ago as i was
recording this the monster hunter game
came out right
and i was like well i was gonna play
that anyway so it's fine but i was
really busy up until these last three
days so i only just picked
it up yesterday right but before that
like right before monster hunter came
out
i had got the new super mario game as
well
so i had played that new super mario
game for like literally four days
and then i was like monster hunters out
alright ceo
i just immediately started a new game i
mean if it's like a really
you know a highly anticipated game that
you're waiting for yeah i get it oh no
but i'm like that with anything right
like if there's like a new game on like
steam that's like oh it's 20
off i guess i'll give it a go like i
feel like i'm one of those like if if
we're comparing it to like people who
eat food right
yeah i'm definitely one of those people
who just takes little bits
off of the buffet but doesn't actually
finish what's on their plate yeah before
they go onto it
whereas there are some people who are
like no i'm getting one thing
and i'm not going to move on to the next
meal until i finish it
okay so you know when it was like
christmas or your birthday
yeah you ever asked for more than one
video game did you ever do that no
you never asked more than one video no i
i did but it was like a hail mary
i'm just like maybe maybe this is the
year that all happened
maybe santa really loves me this year
and then if you get like two or three
games in one
you know birthday of christmas it's like
yeah how do you
whoa whoa yeah where who do i begin with
how do i split this time evenly like
that
that sounds like a first time that is
the most stressful i think my
seven-year-old
life peaked when i got an entire game
console for christmas i got an
n64 and that was like man my career's
peaked i am
life is never gonna peak after this what
am i what am i even living for man yeah
i was i was like that when i got the
game boy advance when i was like five
i was like there's so much power in my
hands
every other every other thing i've ever
done out the window